RICK KLEFFEL: Ladies and
gentlemen, thank you for
joining us here this
afternoon.
My name is Rick Kleffel and I
have a website called The
Agony Column at agonycolumn.com.
And I have the great privilege
to have with me as my guest
and yours, Lee Child.
He's the author of 17 Jack
Reacher novels, from "Killing
Floor," his very first novel--
in first edition hardcover--
to his latest novel, "A
Wanted Man." Thank you
for joining me, Lee.
LEE CHILD: My pleasure,
although this is very
intimidating.
Not only am I the best-dressed,
which is
completely unusual--
[LAUGHTER]
LEE CHILD: Because I had a very
smart event last night,
and I don't carry a bag.
And so what you see
is what you get.
I'm almost the oldest person
here, and the dumbest person
here, probably.
So this is all very unusual.
RICK KLEFFEL: Lee, I'd like to
have you read this little
paragraph here from the very
first book, which I think will
give our audience a good taste
of how you write and who this
man is you write about.
LEE CHILD: Yeah, this
was obviously--
this was probably written in
1995, I would think, this
part, when I was trying
to establish the
character or Reacher.
Told in the first person,
and this is how it goes.
"The coming storm chased me
all the way back east.
I felt I had more than
a storm after me.
I was sick with frustration.
This morning I had been just
one conversation away from
knowing everything.
Now I knew nothing.
The situation had suddenly
turned sour.
I had no backup, no facilities,
no help.
I couldn't rely on
Roscoe or Finley.
I couldn't expect either of them
to agree with my agenda.
And they had troubles of their
own up at the station house.
What had Finley said?
Working under the
enemy's nose?
And I couldn't expect too
much from Picard.
He was already way
out on a limb.
I couldn't count on anybody
but myself.
On the other hand, I had no
laws to worry about, no
inhibitions, no distractions.
I wouldn't have to think about
Miranda, probable cause,
constitutional rights.
I wouldn't have to think
about reasonable
doubt or rules of evidence.
No appeal to any higher
authority for these guys.
Was that fair?
You bet your ass.
They were bad people.
They'd stepped over the
line a long time ago.
Bad people.
What had Finley said?
As bad as they come."
And that gives you, in a
nutshell, Lee's main character
in these novels, Jack Reacher.
And I think that
these novels--
I was thinking about it today.
These novels and this character
are an absolute
monument to the appeal and
the power of pragmatism.
Because I think that Jack
Reacher is the ultimate
pragmatist.
LEE CHILD: Yeah, he is.
Absolutely.
Inasmuch as the character in
the book, he's a total
pragmatist.
He will do whatever
needs doing,
whichever way it will work.
As a wider issue, I think it
goes beyond pragmatism to a
kind of consolation
for people.
Because what Reacher does,
Reacher is the judge, the
jury, and the executioner.
And people say to me, don't
I worry that I am somehow
setting a bad example?
That you shouldn't really walk
up to somebody and shoot them
in the head?
And so am I not suggesting
that this is
something that is not good?
And I say no.
Because actually, I worked in
television for a long time and
I've been a writer for
a long time now.
And the thing that you
eventually learn is that even
the most ordinary people, the
mass audience as a whole, is
very sophisticated at a kind
of instinctive level.
And they understand completely
that we live in a civilized
society where we do need to have
rules and laws and rights
for the accused and
procedures.
We absolutely need to
have those things.
People understand that, and they
do not disagree with it.
But at the same time, it's
intensely frustrating.
So they turn to fiction
for an alternative,
an alternative view.
Where you catch the bad guy in
real life, obviously, yeah,
you arrest him, you read the
Miranda rights, he has a fair
trial, and so on and so forth.
People understand that's
necessary.
But it's boring, so for fiction,
they want to see the
guy shot in the head.
But the very fact that it's
fiction means that they
understand that they can't
have it in real life.
They understand these are not
textbooks for how to live.
They are kind of consolations
for how
frustrating real life is.
RICK KLEFFEL: But I think one of
the appeals of these books
is the textbook-like manner in
which you immerse us in Jack
Reacher's thought process.
It is so much fun to read the
prose that you write to be in
Jack Reacher's head.
And he's like a ticking--
tick, tick, tick.
He's like an instruction
manual for how
to get back at people.
LEE CHILD: Oh, he sure is.
I mean, these are basically
revenge stories.
Because I love revenge.
I think that if somebody stepped
out of line, then you
go get them.
And so I love that kind of
story, and Reacher is really
good at that.
But Reacher--
I mean it's real funny being
here at Google, because
somebody said to me not long
ago, Reacher is a very analog
guy in a digital age.
And he really is.
He sticks to his old-fashioned
routines, his old-fashioned
notions, and there's no
gray with Reacher.
It's all black or white.
And as far as that goes, he's a
real throwback, hundreds if
not thousands of years.
RICK KLEFFEL: Well, I think
that kind of a primitive
nature to him is, again, a big
part of this appeal, because
it cuts to our own kind
of reptilian reaction.
And I'd like you to talk a
little bit about just creating
that prose voice.
Because you did this in the
first person in the first
book, and then leapt
to the third person
in the second book.
Talk about just finding
that right voice.
That isn't something that came
to you easily, I'm guessing.
LEE CHILD: Well, it was a
conscious decision, really.
The prose had to create
the character,
to a certain extent.
And I was imagining a character
who is intelligent,
who is knowledgeable,
and so on.
But he's very antisocial.
He's very isolated.
And he doesn't talk a lot.
And I've met one or two people
like that, and their manner of
talking is very fractured,
very fragmented, because
they're not accustomed to
having conversations.
And so they're somewhat
incoherent, somewhat
stop-start in the way
they communicate.
So for the purposes of creating
the character, I
wanted that kind of naive
style, as if this is an
inarticulate intelligent
person talking to you.
I also wanted, frankly, to be
distinctive commercially,
where I wanted a style that
was identifiably mine.
So I developed that very
terse, stripped down--
I use a lot of sentence
fragments.
I ignore most of the
rules of grammar.
Just to try and make
it a unique voice.
Because voice is what
storytelling is all about.
And if you go to a MFA or some
kind of university class, and
people talk about voice, what
they tend to mean is just a
vague concept about style.
Voice and style become almost
interchangeable.
And it's really not
that at all.
Voice is literally a voice.
Because one of the things that
fascinates me is the history
of storytelling, which is one
of those things that we
actually don't know
anything about.
Because as soon as language was
developed amongst humans,
which is several hundred
thousand years ago, as far as
we can tell, at some point after
that, then storytelling
was evolved.
And we don't know when that
happened, either.
It's perfectly reasonable to
think it could have been
100,000, 150,000 years ago
that we started using
syntactical language abilities
to start talking about things
that had not happened to people
that don't exist.
In other words, making
up fiction.
But of course, as soon as that
first happened-- there's no
record of it, there's no audio
recordings, we don't know
anything about it.
But what we do know is that it
was clearly, for almost its
entire history, up until
possibly about 170 years ago,
storytelling for most people
was mostly oral.
It's really only the middle of
the 19th century where most
regular people started
to read off the page.
And so almost 99.99% of
storytelling's history was oral.
And the bestsellers, so-called,
of their day were
people with a compelling
delivery, with an attractive
voice and a compelling style.
Would be sitting around telling
a story, and they had
maybe 30 people listening, and
the next guy along had 10
people listening, so this guy is
the bestseller of his day.
So storytelling is totally about
voice, and voice is a
very literal and
specific thing.
It's the voice of the person
telling you the story.
The more attractive it
is, the more into the
story you will be.
So I felt that developing a
voice was absolutely key.
And I think you can tell
that subliminally.
The books that you like, the
writers that you like, are
likely to have some kind of
distinctive delivery to their
story, rather than just a sort
of bland normality to it.
RICK KLEFFEL: Well, what you say
is so true, because humans
are a narrative species.
We define ourselves
through stories.
If I ask you, who are
you, you're going
to tell me a story.
Maybe some fiction
or fact in there.
LEE CHILD: Yeah, I mean,
that's true.
There's a movement, actually,
amongst anthropologists, Homo
sapiens is what they call it.
They want to call
it Pan narrans--
in other words, the
storytelling ape.
And it does seem absolutely key
that we do tell stories.
RICK KLEFFEL: Now the stories
in your books are
driven by this man.
One of the things I think is
very interesting about these
stories, they're very America.
You obviously are less so.
LEE CHILD: Can you tell?
RICK KLEFFEL: But you do a great
job of incorporating, I
think, the British contribution
to the mystery
genre and incorporating it into
your American character.
I know I'm not the first person
to comment on how
Jack's a walking Sherlock
Holmes.
And everything he does--
the plots of the books are
affected by the fact that
everything he looks at,
everything he sees, he starts
making deductions about.
LEE CHILD: Yeah, I mean, it's
fascinating that people say,
this is a quintessentially
American character.
And that's only true
in passing.
I mean, Reacher is a mythic and
legendary character that
has been around in fairly
similar form for literally
thousands of years.
Every culture that we know about
that has a narrative
tradition has invented this
character over and over again
over the centuries--
the mysterious stranger, the
noble loner, the knight
errant, the person of some kind
of odd nobility who is
banished from his milieu and
sentenced to wander the land
to do good, either as an
imperative or just as a
product of his nature.
That happens in Japan, the ronin
stories where a samurai
is disowned by his master and
then just wanders as an
independent.
It happened all through the
Middle Ages in Europe, the
knight errant.
Various key components, the
idea of fallen nobility.
And Reacher was a West Point
graduate and a major in the US
Army, and that was supposed to
give that hint of some status
from which he's fallen.
And so he is American, only in
the sense that that character
has to have an empty, dangerous
frontier feel in
which to operate.
Which was fine in Europe
700 , 800 years ago.
Europe was an empty, dangerous
continent with a frontier.
But of course, over the
centuries, Europe became no
longer that.
So that character was
essentially forced to migrate
to somewhere where there still
was emptiness and a frontier.
And suddenly, those myths
started to show up in
Australia and the US,
especially in
19th-century Westerns.
That character, the classic
character from the Westerns,
you see him all the time
in Zane Grey's stories.
The rider that comes in off
the range at exactly the
crucial time.
In exchange for a woman-cooked
meal, he unsheathes his rifle,
takes care of the problem, and
rides off into the sunset.
Now, that character seems
so American, but
it's actually not.
It was a direct import
from medieval Europe.
And it wasn't invented in
medieval Europe, either.
Is was there a direct import
from Scandinavian sagas and
legends and even older
Anglo-Saxon legends.
Clearly, there's a need amongst
the audience to have
that character, quite clearly
because we would like to have
that character.
If we're in deep shit, then it's
great if we could imagine
that somebody will show up in
the nick of time and solve our
problem for us.
So we've invented that
character repeatedly.
And all I did was to give it
a kind of reality-based
plausibility in the
21st century.
RICK KLEFFEL: Now one of the
things that I think does make
your work really convincing is
you have a great vision of
America, in that you look at
the places that most people
don't look at.
And I'm wondering, you know--
the suburbs, the kind of empty
parts of the bad cities, the
sin city in the latest book,
the unky part of the cities
where people don't go.
And I'm wondering, when you
create these places, do you
create them with an idea of, I'm
going to have to stage a
scene here?
Are you like an architect
and a city planner
as well as a writer?
LEE CHILD: Yeah, kind of.
Although a lot of that is just
fascination generally.
Being an outsider, I see
everything with a fresh eye.
And that is so valuable,
I think.
I gloss over nothing, because
I've never seen it before.
Any place I go to, I'm seeing
for the first time, probably,
and it makes an impression.
And I see the parts that other
people no longer see.
And I think that really
comes through.
I think that's very important.
But yeah, I love the
whole thing.
I love every scuzzy little
thing, every big thing.
I was in Vegas one time,
and we were in
this terrible hotel--
actually, I liked the hotel, but
everybody else thought it
was terrible.
But across the street was this
bar that was nothing but a
sort of rectangle made out of
cinder blocks, painted dirty
white, probably painted
white 18 years ago,
and it was all filthy.
No windows or anything
like that.
It had a door-- it had no
sign at all, but it had,
hand-painted with a fat
paintbrush on the wall was its
advertisement.
Four words--
"Cold Beer,
Dirty Girls." [LAUGHTER]
LEE CHILD: What a place!
That's the sort of place
that I love.
[LAUGHTER]
RICK KLEFFEL: Now I'd like you
to talk a little bit about
plotting these books.
How much of this--
each of these books, what's so
much fun is that we know
pretty much what to expect
going into every book.
Yet you manage to, for 17 books,
write books that each
book feels fresh.
They're fun, they're enjoyable,
there's a really
powerful vision of America and
a gut connection for the
reader there.
It seems like, as a writer, you
must have a kind of Jack
Reacher nature, just to adapt
to what you have to do.
LEE CHILD: Well, they're fresh
because I took one key
decision at the very beginning,
which was really
because I did not want to jump
into the same river that
everybody else was in.
I saw no point in going
head-to-head with established
people, in terms of the
shape of their series.
And everybody else who writes
a series, I think literally
everybody else at that time
anyway, was writing a series
that was, broadly speaking,
a soap opera--
either location-based or
employment-based or both.
And typically, you would have a
cop in LA or you would have
a private eye in Boston, or
you would have a police
lieutenant in Chicago, and
that was the series.
And it seemed to me that they
were being done so well, why
compete with that
head-to-head?
Plus, it also seemed to me the
one smart thing I ever did,
the one inspired piece of
thinking that I ever did, is
I'd looked ahead.
And you can't ever say, yeah,
I'm going to write a book, and
18 years later, I'm still
going to be doing it.
Because that's ridiculous.
That's very unlikely
to happen.
But you have to take into
account, maybe you will.
Maybe it might work, and maybe
you will get 15 or
20 years into it.
How are you going
to feel then?
And I felt that if I had
done something that was
specifically based somewhere,
in something, it would've
gotten very boring after,
say, 10 books.
So if he had been a cop in New
York, that would have limited
me to cop stuff in one
particular city.
And I foresaw a problem with
that, so I decided he would
have no job and no location, so
that he could be anywhere
and do anything.
And that's what keeps
it fresh for me.
And that also then liberates
me to do the method that I
use, which is not to
plot anything.
I don't plot, I don't outline,
I don't think about it.
I just start him out somewhere
and see what happens.
RICK KLEFFEL: Really?
LEE CHILD: Yeah.
I have literally no concept of
what the story is going to be
about or what the thing
is going to be or how
it's going to end.
People say, what, you don't know
how it's going to end?
I don't know what's going to
happen in the next line.
And I don't want to know.
Because for me, the story
is the magic.
And if I outlined it, which
lots of writers do--
you know, they make an outline
of varying degrees of detail.
If I did that, then I would have
told myself the story.
I would know how it came out.
And I would be bored with it,
and I would want to go on to
the next story.
If I then had to sit down and
type out 500 pages worth of
that story, I would
be bored, because
I know how it finishes.
It would be like
doing it twice.
I only want to do it once.
So I start at the beginning with
some kind of good idea
for the beginning, and then
I see what happens.
And what happens is
like real life.
We don't know.
We have no idea what's
going to happen.
You don't know what's going to
happen in one hour from now.
And that's how I write.
Page by page, it's
all new to me.
RICK KLEFFEL: Well, one of the
things I think you do very
well, too, is in the characters
who appear, the
one-book characters, you do
a great job of giving us
characters who have different
levels of their faults.
They're incomplete.
In the latest book, we have
Sheriff Goodman and we have a
couple of agents, and they
all have problems.
They say, oh man, I
made a mistake.
These are kind of flawed
characters.
And I'd like you to talk about
just crafting a novel where
the flaws of your characters
help create the plot.
LEE CHILD: Well, we're very,
very weird, writers, because
I'm not making up a
character at all.
I'm meeting people.
These are real to me.
And that's the admission
that you have to make.
You're sitting there at the
computer, dealing with people
that are real.
To me, anyway, the
events are real.
And often, my editor will say to
me something like, wouldn't
it be better if this happened
after that?
And I say, well, yeah,
it probably would be
better, but it didn't.
[LAUGHTER]
LEE CHILD: Because it's
really happening.
For the six months I'm writing
the book, this is real.
And so these characters are
just real people to me.
I sort of dream them up, but
then there they are.
And I describe them, I let them
do whatever it is they're
doing, and yeah, they're
regular people.
They're good at some things,
not good at other things.
And the flawed stuff-- you know,
I try and stay away from
"flawed," in terms
of, you know, how
literary theory goes.
You've got to have these
flawed characters.
I don't like flawed
characters.
I don't like miserable
people with defects.
So as far as possible, I make
the characters good at their
jobs, decent people.
But they do, they make errors,
they make mistakes, they have
blind spots.
And that then creates
opportunities
for the story, yeah.
RICK KLEFFEL: One of the things
you've done very well,
too, is move through all sorts
of different kind of genres, I
think, within your books.
The first book has, I think, a
distinct element of the horror
genre in it.
It's the small town
with a secret.
And you've had other
books where they're
more a military slant.
Some are more a mystery slant.
And I'm wondering, is that
something you just
discover as you write?
Or do you think, maybe it's time
to do this kind of novel.
LEE CHILD: No, I'm fairly
impatient about genre.
I think that this endless
passing of genre--
is this suspense or is it
romantic suspense or is it
horror or is it this or that--
I pay no attention
to that at all.
Because for me as a reader--
and everything I do is based
on how I feel as a reader.
For me as a reader, there are
only two kinds of books.
There's the kind that will make
you miss your stop on the
subway and the kind
that don't.
It's that simple.
And the kind that make you
miss your stop can be
nonfiction, could be history,
could be politics, sociology.
If it's an engaging argument
well told, then
you're in that book.
So I have no patience at all
for, oh, I better do something
that's slightly more horror
or slightly more mystery.
Like I say, just start
at the beginning and
see what comes out.
And the image that I use to
explain it is, you're like a
movie stunt man.
You've got to fall off
that high building.
And out of sight of the camera
in the street, there's a fire
department airbag that you're
going to land on, or hopefully
you're going to land on it.
And it's a large airbag.
And in one corner it's marked
"thriller," in one corner it's
marked "mystery," in one corner
it's marked "suspense,"
in one corner it's marked "crime
fiction." You're going
to land on that bag, but you
don't know exactly where.
You might be nearer one corner
than the other, but you only
know that retrospectively.
I don't set out thinking,
OK, I'm going to write a
sociologically gripping
crime fiction book.
I just write a book.
And somebody else reads it
and says, oh, this is a
sociologically gripping
crime fiction book.
And I say, OK, fine, whatever.
RICK KLEFFEL: As a keen observer
of American society
and mores, I think one of things
you do is really give
us a raw feeling for the way we
look and the way we live.
And I think that's really part
and parcel, that's probably
why your books are described as
quintessential American books.
LEE CHILD: Yeah, probably.
It probably takes a foreigner to
observe this stuff in that
kind of detail or with that
kind of perspective.
I don't know.
But you mentioned Sherlock
Holmes earlier on, and that's
indicative of the relationship
that a writer has with the
apparent effect.
Because Sherlock Holmes,
I love Sherlock Holmes.
But from a writer's perspective,
it's just the
most outrageous con
trick of all time.
Because you've got Sherlock
Holmes, who's whatever he's
doing, smoking his pipe, he's
looking out the window of
Baker Street, and he sees this
guy walking towards his door.
And he says to Watson, ah,
Watson, clearly this is a
baker from Shoreditch whose been
out of work for exactly
nine months.
And sure enough, the guy shows
up in the living room, and he
says he's a baker from
Shoreditch whose been out of
work for nine months,
and Sherlock Holmes
looks like a genius.
Except it's Conan Doyle who's
writing both ends of that
transaction.
Of course he's right.
In reality, the guy would come
up and say, no, I'm not.
I'm a bricklayer from
Islington, or
something like that.
So with all of this so-called
perception, it looks great,
because I'm defining both
ends of the deal.
So it's largely an illusion,
more than anything else.
RICK KLEFFEL: Oh, that's, I
think, the real key to being
an effective writer of anything
is the release of
information.
And one of the things that you
do very well, especially in
the latest book, is we see this
set of events and we know
this, and we see that set of
events and we know that, and
we know everything
that's going on.
And as readers, part of the
fun for us is to see the
characters catch up with us.
LEE CHILD: Yeah, there's
two ways of doing it.
You either state the
circumstances and let the
reader be more powerful than the
characters, or vice versa.
You have a kind a confusing
mystery and the characters
lead the reader through it.
Both ways work really well.
Because there's really only one
technique that works in a
book of this type, in my
opinion, a suspense book.
I mean, suspense is a strange
word to use for a book,
because all books have
suspense in them.
Otherwise, why would anybody
ever finish one?
There's got to be some reason
why you keep going to the end.
But I suppose what we call
suspense fiction emphasizes
the suspense.
And you get into
all kinds of--
there are dozens of classes
and dozens of courses, and
they all have--
one of their modules
is entitled, how
do you create suspense?
And my feeling about that is
that the very form of that
question immediately leads
you down the wrong path.
Because the form of the
question, how do you create
suspense, is a kind of active
question, similar to how do
you bake a cake?
And we all know how to bake
a cake, or at least,
theoretically we do.
Not that I've ever baked one,
but I've seen it done.
And what you do with baking
a cake is you have some
ingredients and you have the
clear implication that the
higher quality the ingredients,
the better the
cake is going to be.
You've know you've got to mix
these ingredients together,
again with the clear implication
that the more
thoroughly and conscientiously
you mix them together, the
better the cake will be.
You then put it in the oven,
with the implication that the
more exact the temperature
and timing, the better
the cake will be.
So you immediately start
to think of that
as a process question.
And it's the wrong question
for suspense.
The real question is not
how do you bake a cake?
It is, how do you make
your family hungry?
And the way you make your family
hungry is you make them
wait four hours for dinner.
And that's what you
do with a book.
You imply a question, and then
you do not answer it until the
end of the book.
And you do that, as you go
along, in miniature.
You imply a question and you
don't answer it until the end
of the chapter or the end
of the paragraph.
Or even your sentence
construction, you flip it
around so that the first half of
the sentence is answered by
the second half of
the sentence.
And that creates this
unstoppable momentum.
Because if there's one thing
that humans are hard-wired to
do, it is to wait around for
the answer to a question.
We learned that in television
a long time ago.
I worked in television from
the end of the '70s to the
middle of the '90s, and a huge
revolution went on in
the way we did it.
There was something that
nobody had in 1980 that
everybody had in 1990 that
absolutely revolutionized the
way that we worked.
And you notice I haven't
said what it was.
You're now thinking, well, what
did nobody have in 1980?
Because I've implied a
question, and I'm not
answering it.
And you want to know, right?
What nobody had in 1980 and they
did have in 1990 was a
remote control.
So in the old days, your
sequencing of programming, you
could get away with a lot.
Because if somebody wanted to
change the channel, they'd
have to get their ass off the
sofa and go and do it.
And you could rely on the fact
that they probably wouldn't.
By 1990, it was dead easy
to change channels.
They would be flipping around
to see if anything stopped.
The end of a part, a commercial,
anything, they
would be changing channels
like mad.
And we had to work out a
way of defeating that.
And we started out, we invented
a process that still
exists in sports now.
Its last remnant is visible in
sports, particularly baseball,
where during the fourth inning,
typically in the
fourth inning of baseball,
people have got some idea of
the way the game is going.
Their initial impulse to watch
baseball is fading away.
So at the end of the top
of the fourth, you
ask a trivia question.
Like, who was the pitcher who
gave up Lou Gehrig's first
grand slam?
And then you do the commercials,
and then you
answer the trivia question at
the beginning of the bottom of
the fourth.
And even if you know who gave
up Lou Gehrig's first grand
slam, even if you don't care,
even if you've never heard of
Lou Gehrig, even if you don't
know what a grand slam is,
there is something that makes
you want to stick around for
that answer.
And that's very powerful
with humans.
And that's the way to
create suspense.
You ask a question, and then
you refuse to answer it for
hundreds of pages.
And people will stick
around for it.
And the key text in that area
is a book by John Grisham.
You know, John Grisham's a very
popular author, often
overlooked in terms
of quality.
But he's a very smart guy,
Grisham, I think, and
underestimated in terms of
how experimental he is.
And he did this one book called
"The Runaway Jury." And
none of the classic elements
are present in "The Runaway
Jury." People tell you you've
got to have sympathetic
characters that you care about,
so you follow them
through their perils, and
all that kind of stuff.
"Runaway Jury" has got no
sympathetic characters.
It has bad guys and
worse guys.
It has nothing in it whatsoever,
except what is the
verdict going to be
in this trial?
And that's the only question.
And you read that book like a
locomotive, because you need
the answer.
RICK KLEFFEL: Now, what
shows did you work on?
LEE CHILD: When I was
in television?
I worked for Granada Television
in Manchester,
England, which was at that
time a tremendous drama
producer, also documentary
producer.
But drama-wise, you saw it all
over "Masterpiece Theatre." We
did "Brideshead Revisited,"
"Jewel in the Crown," "Prime
Suspect," "Cracker," all those
great British shows.
RICK KLEFFEL: Well, that
explains that.
Now one of things that I think
makes these books really fun
to read, too, is you have
a very absolutely
deadpan sense of humor.
I mean, it's just smashed to the
ground and so flat we can
barely see it, but it's
really there.
And your books, they're
hilarious.
LEE CHILD: I think so, yeah.
I mean, a lot of people
wouldn't--
you know, humor is not the first
thing people think about
when they think about a Reacher
book, but I think he's
very funny.
But yeah, very subliminal
stealth humor, very sardonic.
And I like those parts a lot.
I liked writing them, yeah.
RICK KLEFFEL: As you've been
creating the character, one of
things that's nice about him is
that even though he lives
entirely outside of society,
and he's I guess what you'd
call off the grid, he has none
of the kind of unsavory taint
of a survivalist or somebody who
claims to be off the grid.
And that's a delicate
balancing act,
I think, for you.
LEE CHILD: Yeah, I mean, off
the grid does imply that
you're some kind of weirdo or
you are planning secession,
you know, you want
to make Montana a
separate country or something.
And he's not that kind of
off the grid person.
He just doesn't want
to live anywhere.
He doesn't want the hassle
of owning a house or
dealing with anything.
So he takes advantage of the
available infrastructure,
which is fantastic in America.
You have a constant parade of
diners and motels and little
stores and diners and motels.
Why would anybody do
it any different,
is Reacher's opinion.
For $20 a night, you can
find a place to stay.
You can buy a new outfit
for $25, $30.
You can eat in a diner
for $4 or $5.
Why would he want a house?
He has this rigorously
logical approach.
What would a house bring
him that he wants?
And the answer is nothing.
So it's not so much that
he's off the grid.
He is just a wanderer.
RICK KLEFFEL: Yeah, that's true,
because it's not like
he's opposed to government
or the rules of society.
LEE CHILD: No, he was
respectful of the
hierarchy in the Army.
He's got no problem with
hierarchy in general or
government or anything
like that.
It's purely utilitarian
for him.
Why doesn't he carry
a cell phone?
Well, who would ever call him?
There's no point in it.
So he won't do anything that
there's no point in.
RICK KLEFFEL: Well, of course if
you told everybody here 20
years ago the government's going
to strap a radio control
device so we can locate
you at any moment?
And I think that's in
this book, too.
LEE CHILD: Yeah, I think that
is fantastic, actually.
You know, think back
20, 25 years.
If a bill had gone to Congress
saying that every American
must wear a wireless transponder
so they can be
tracked everywhere all the time,
there would have been
total outrage.
But of course we've done it to
ourselves voluntarily, which
is very strange.
RICK KLEFFEL: Along
with ubiquitous
surveillance, too, since--
LEE CHILD: Yeah, but
not as bad as it is
in London, for instance.
I mean, that really is a
surveillance society.
One quarter of the entire
planet's CCTV
cameras are in London.
And any person, anyone of you
goes to London for some
reason, you are on some camera
all day and all night.
It's really bizarre.
RICK KLEFFEL: Now,
do we have any
questions from the audience?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So this is not quite about your
writing style, but more
about sort of your opinion.
So as you know, there's a movie
coming out, and I was
curious to know your thoughts
of the casting.
I bring this up because,
obviously, Jack Reacher is
6'5" and he's fair-haired
and blond-eyed.
And then in the movie,
he's not quite
depicted the same way.
He's a lot shorter, and
darker-haired, et cetera.
So I also saw his face on one of
your books at the airport,
and so I was like, oh my god,
that's like totally not
representative.
So I was just kind of curious
of your thoughts on that.
Like did you have any say?
Or was it just kind
of like, surprise!
LEE CHILD: No, not
contractually, not legally,
because typically, a movie
contract is very, very
restrictive.
And a movie contract is a
hilarious thing, legally.
It's, generally speaking,
longer than the book.
And it has all kinds
of bizarre clauses.
By the time you reach page 400,
you realize what it is
you're actually selling.
And What you're selling is
a license for a dramatic
production to be shown anywhere
in the known universe.
And then there's a rider saying,
"or parts not yet
discovered."
It's an immense, it's
a huge, binding
thing, a movie contract.
Really, if an author asks for
approval or veto or anything
like that, that's the same thing
as just not selling it.
Because they won't do it.
Because it needs to be done--
it can't be done by committee.
This is their project.
But having said all of that,
the people that made this
movie are out and out
crazed Reacher fans.
They totally are.
They know as much as he
does about the books.
They have read the books
obsessively.
They love the character.
So they were very,
very nice to me.
They included me at every step
of the way, I bet more than
any author has ever
been included.
And of course, there were
two key points.
People say, did I have a say?
And I say, yes I did.
I had 100% total control.
Because it was my choice whether
to sell it or not.
If I sold it to the movies,
that's one decision.
If I didn't, that's
another decision.
So there is 100% control.
And then what happened, the
movie took a long time to get
off the ground.
Because it's complicated
making movies.
Everybody's got to say
yes on the same day.
And then the odds against that
happening are like winning the
Power Ball.
So it takes years and
years and years.
And of course during those years
and years and years, the
books were doing very well.
The books were growing bigger
and bigger and bigger as a
book franchise.
So by the time the movie
actually went into production,
the books were important enough
in the world that they
had to approach it very
respectfully.
Not that they wouldn't have
wanted to, because like I
said, they were big
fans of the books.
But it did mean I was
included more.
Not so much because they needed
my input on anything,
because they were completely
sure about how to do it.
It wasn't that they
wanted my input.
They just wanted to kind
of celebrate with me.
Look, we're doing this.
This is happening,
it's working,
it's going to be here.
So I was very involved.
And again, there was a point
where the financer was there,
the whole thing was rolling,
it was just about the cast,
who was going to be cast.
And we went to dinner, and they
said, we want Tom Cruise
to play Reacher.
And I know for a fact that if
I had freaked out at that
point, they would have abandoned
it, I'm certain.
But I didn't freak out.
Because in a wider sense--
and this is something, again,
that fascinates me, that a
book exists entirely in
the imaginative realm.
And I honestly believe that a
book is a two-way transaction,
that my imagination,
specifically, and your
imagination, specifically,
together create the book.
I've put something into it.
The act of reading, you've
put something into it.
Then the book exists.
And it can be incredibly vivid
and incredibly detailed and
hyper-real.
But it's in the imaginative
realm.
There is no reality to it.
Then if you want to make a movie
out of it, even though
the movie is, again, fiction and
it's a story and it's full
of magic and tricks and all
that kind of stuff,
fundamentally a movie exists
in the physical world.
It's no longer purely
imaginative.
It's in the physical world,
because you've got to have
real people and they're
acting in real spaces.
And so you jump from the
imaginative to the physical.
And as soon as you do that, the
physical reality starts to
define things.
In terms of the casting, for
instance, the physical reality
is that the actor
has to exist.
It's that simple.
You've got to choose one of the
pool of existing actors.
And so yeah, Reacher is 6'5" in
the books, and he's ugly,
and he's got scars, and he's
generally speaking a little
bit sort of beat-up-looking
and huge and so on.
So you think, fine.
So you go to Hollywood,
and you start to
look for that actor.
You're not going to find that
actor, because that
actor does not exist.
There's something about the
technology of film, and
cameras in general--
and again, I learned this years
ago on television--
there is something odd about
the lens that will not
accommodate big people.
Which is really why there
are no big actors.
There are literally no big
actors, none at all.
And so if you're going to make
a movie, you've got to deal
with the existing pool of real
physical actors, and you've
got to pick one.
And therefore, it becomes
immediately apparent that
there's no way we're going to
get an exact physical match
for Reacher, because that
actor does not exist.
And you can say, well, yeah,
but what about this guy?
What about that guy?
What about this other guy?
And that conversation has
been going on for
a year and a half.
What about this guy?
Well, that guy's dead.
[LAUGHTER]
LEE CHILD: What about
this guy?
Well, that guy's
103 years old.
And so it goes back and forth,
and you end up with a kind of
short list of potential
suggestions, all of whom are
not very big.
Because as I said, there
are no big actors.
You're talking about this guy
who's two inches bigger than
this other guy, and they're both
eight inches shorter than
Reacher, so why worry
about it?
So what I wanted to do,
ultimately, in that
split-second that I had to
think about it in that
restaurant when they told me
that they want to cast Tom
Cruise, is it was clear that we
were never going to get the
outside of Reacher, because that
is just not available.
So what I wanted to do was to
get the inside of Reacher, as
close as possible.
And again, I know actors.
I've worked with them
all my life.
When I was 22 years old, almost
23 to be fair, I worked
with four actors--
Laurence Olivier, John Gielgud,
Alec Guinness, and
Ralph Richardson, who were
pretty heavyweight actors.
And so I'm familiar
with actors.
I know what they can do.
You can sort of look at their
past body of work and you can
figure out what are
they capable of.
And I felt that Cruise was
absolutely 100% capable of
doing the inside of Reacher, the
stillness, the quiet, the
menace, the intensity--
he could do that.
And therefore, I was really
happy about it.
Really happy about it.
And I've seen the movie twice,
and he absolutely nails it.
So it's this very
strange thing.
It's like looping the loop
in a small airplane.
You have to go away from
the book in order to
come back to it.
And you know, the casting has
caused a lot of consternation.
And I'm deeply grateful about
that, frankly, because the
idea that I've created this
character that people actually
care who plays him in the movies
is a wonderful thing.
That's the biggest possible
compliment.
I'm thrilled by it.
But we are in this awkward
situation at the moment where
the movie comes out
December 21st.
And I sincerely hope you go see
it, because if you do see
it, you're going to think,
you know what?
That was pretty good,
because he nails it.
RICK KLEFFEL: Well, one of the
things that struck me when you
were talking was how vivid
your books are as reading
experiences.
And I think that's one of the
things that makes them so
powerful to us.
And I think this kind of work
stands right next to any
kitchen-window epiphany piece
of literature, I think, in
terms of connecting to our
narrative reading instincts.
So I'd like you to talk a little
bit about connecting
with readers on that level of
language, that kind of reptile
level of experience.
LEE CHILD: Yeah, well, I think
that part of the answer to
that is what I said earlier, at
the beginning of the movie
answer, which is that it
is a two-way street.
I don't think we can
underestimate that.
I don't mean in terms
of the work done.
I do all the work.
You have all the fun.
But your imagination is just as
crucial in this transaction
as mine is.
It's a collaborative exercise.
RICK KLEFFEL: It's what
you leave out.
LEE CHILD: Yeah.
And therefore, actually, if you
leave stuff out, if you
leave the characters and the
situation as an empty vessel,
to a certain extent, that leaves
room for the reader's
imagination to swarm in there
and fill in the details with
their own convictions.
And I think that's what makes
a successful reading
experience.
Give the reader enough room to
do some of it themselves.
Because Reacher, for instance,
is never really described
other than very vaguely.
His general shape and size,
his general hair color or
whatever-- he's not really
described at all.
And yet everybody has a very
specific image of what he
looks like, and that's because
they're investing.
You know, the room is there, and
they're occupying it with
their own projection.
And I think that
is what makes--
it's my reptile brain connected
to theirs, and
together, we're creating
the story.
And I think the sort of books
that don't work are the sort
of books that over-specify
everything and try and
dominate the reader, try and
command the reader, rather
than give the reader room
and opportunity.
RICK KLEFFEL: Now, one of the
things that we like about
these books is the way, from
book to book, we never know
what's going to happen
with Reacher and the
women in the books.
And I think you seem to have a
little bit of a devil in you,
with regards to that.
LEE CHILD: Well, you know, the
women in the books, there's
been a couple of books where
he does not get laid.
And you know, that is
a tragedy, really.
[LAUGHTER]
LEE CHILD: But like I said,
I don't plan it.
And it got to the fifth
book, I think, and
there was this lawyer.
I think she was called Alice.
She was a lawyer
down in Texas.
She was from New York, and
she's representing
disadvantaged people in Texas.
And she was this really
nice character.
So I was imagining, sure,
OK, here we go.
This is the love interest
in this book.
But then she sort of turned
out to be gay.
There was this little exchange
where she just, she was gay,
and that was that.
And so he was unrequited
in that book.
But generally speaking, yeah,
you know, think about it from
my point of view.
Like I said, these people
are real to me.
So I'm sitting there in my
office, and I'm going to spend
five or six months with
a made-up woman.
And you'd better believe
she's going to be cute.
[LAUGHTER]
LEE CHILD: I mean, why
would I make up a
woman that was a dog?
You know?
I want to have a good
six months.
So I'm sitting there with this
made-up person, and yeah,
she's going to be cool.
Absolutely.
And so I'm into her, Reacher's
going to be into her.
RICK KLEFFEL: I believe
that our time
is up for this afternoon.
Ladies and gentlemen, we've been
privileged to have with
us one of America's, and
the world's, foremost
writers, Lee Child.
And you can buy his books.
He'll sign them.
I'd say buy this one.
If you've never read him before,
you have 16 fabulous
books to read.
It's the thrill of looking
forward to
stuff, to these books.
You'll find out.
You will find out.
LEE CHILD: Thank you.
RICK KLEFFEL: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]